any advice when you want to change
careers change them that's my
advice everybody overthinks everything
everybody Pond everything like the best
strategies to do like everybody
debating cynicism everybody
cares about all the details like who
gives a that's it like you don't
need me on Instagram live
telling you to do it you don't need your
mom to do it just do it like if
you're so miserable and you want
to check and change careers change
careers like if I thought
through everything I've done in my life
I wouldn't have done anything none of it
made sense hey let's document everything
and then create micro content let's
invest in these
companies that nobody's ever
heard of let's sell wine on the
internet like do